welcome to this video playing King Leck
King Leck from Russia new opponent but
in the old handle just never played it
before okay probably a bank Oh No benoni
yeah if if someone starts to think of
that that stage of the game it's because
they are looking for coffee or they
really don't know what they're doing
okay maybe okay just just play play a
normal set up with 93 maybe e5 was a
possibility but let's just play some
potassium you will probably play these
six anyway even if he spends 20 seconds
huh that's weird oh it's maybe really
has a lag here the name king like has
maybe programmatic however if he has
such luck regularly you shouldn't even
be allowed to play in this rating poor
it's a bit bit strange
he has a pretty high leg
huh that's that's really hard to play
against but he is rotated me so much
that I screwed up the move order you six
okay no he gets in rupee eight quickly
Bishop e3 energy form I like the move
age three yeah okay it's not such a big
problem you can play this with king of
one it's not a big deal wow really yeah
I always have my doubts if they destroy
their own pawn structure like that but
maybe it really is possible right age
for 94 m well that's possible yeah maybe
just try to get rid of the night okay
here i can take and play Queen d3 and
just um just a simple approach
ok see playing be five maybe I wonder if
g4 is a movie em yeah i think it is
making some use of the fact that i have
not cancelled now after taking taking
you cannot take on g4 tu tu roop g1
winning in the Queen and yeah okay this
is of course them again for me as i have
now f94 as a possibility but first let's
let's connect the rooks and go from them
okay so nitey for em Bishop b2 would be
one assist just good provide and maybe
Bishop g7 s not that terrible but I have
night h4 now as well night h4 to f5
queen is seven now okay
interesting yeah this is some case where
I certainly have more than one good move
I can never really take that so I can I
might as well just play even at night
age for you still had to Queenie Sam
yeah now i can play night edge form as
as i have the e4 night safely protected
yeah in the night the night arriving on
f5 should normally be the end of the
game standing two nights on f1 and f5 is
normally not possible no I don't release
yeah I counter play if he goes Bishop b5
I can take on d6 night f takes d6s
Bishop d6 Knight f6 wins everything I
also yeah yeah it this does not help but
I don't think he had anything anything
great so i can i can really take him
nothing nothing better check yeah i can
take with the Queen right
yeah maybe just Knight f6 some takes
Queen takes I'm threatening Queen 7j
3709 f5 both looks both your deadly yeah
still look roughly seven right that is
Queen SL s the the big threat
check checkmate yeah it I made a I made
something that something stupid in the
opening maybe I can somehow use this
move order I'm not sure though it's a
bit strange am because he has not played
t6 but this gives them the stems o to
flick in this movement if you just
theoretically speaking would have this
position I can't play Bishop b3 here as
Bishop h6 is nothing to fear but Knight
g4 is an entirely different matter after
this Bishop b3 is nonsense due to this
because I definitely don't want to give
up this Bishop when this Bishop is still
on the board so I cannot play that at
all so I basically yeah okay I can play
Bishop e2 but yeah I don't want that
this is this is not a problem though
this is even theoretically known
position but I in play to play it very
mmm enterprisingly now with Bishop f5 g4
is even a movie g-form but okay I took
an Bishop g5 and their own ta probably
should seek for improvements after Queen
d7 this structure looks really
attractive for why i believe and then
just do four move maybe b5 he needs to
get some sort of play yeah b5 I guess
this is a good idea it's not really um
I'm not really threatening to take on f5
or something like that this is some now
really really really good cam Fisher p 2
this is immediately exploding him went
here p 5 p 3 and now I'm threatening
night age 42 f5 and
there's not much not much that black can
do night EG Fife is also strong okay but
this must be this simply must be very
good check check no yeah it was okay he
really couldn't do much ham to to get
come to play he should have done done
that like b5 here this is the real point
where black can get something which
might even questioned all this b5 him
this is this is definite counter playful
black not sure how i should play then
compounds to play 92 and that's not
really a move that i think i would have
played now this is probably what black
should do maybe i should have played a 4
then make sure that there's not so much
counterplay happening I don't mind that
he maybe get the night to before it's
not the big deal those weaknesses here
don't go away yeah a force better okay
thanks for watching